[Música]
revista de prensa hoy viernes aquí en
directo américa de france 24 y me
acompaña el estudio rosa pérez más de un
rosa ya finalizamos entonces esta semana
bien cargada de información pero también
con y no va a ser un día particular
porque hoy hay mucha información
internacional abrimos esta revista de
prensa con un poco distinto al que hemos
venido dando desde que rusia inició esta
inversión a ucrania rosa porque poco más
de 15 días de las presidenciales
francesas parece que las elecciones no
ocupan el centro mediático ni incluso
para los medios nacionales hablamos de
los medios francesa por supuesto buenos
días raúl exactamente no no sería
extraño de hecho sería muy común
encontrar en las portadas de los
principales medios de comunicación de
francia pues referencias a esta campaña
para las elecciones presidenciales sin
embargo no acaba de ser del todo así no
lo en montoro ejemplo sí que es verdad
que titula presidencial programas con
cálculos un poco ambiguos pero sin
embargo la foto y la gran atención no de
la portada está destacada a esta visita
de vaivén a europa con este titular la
el regreso con fuerza de eeuu a europa
pasemos al medio también de comunicación
oración que dedica toda la portada a
este primer mes de guerra en ucraniano
dice un mes después ucrania pasa a la
ofensiva y para terminar tenemos le
figaro que sí que hace referencia pues a
las empresas francesas pero digamos
entre comillas en víctimas de una trampa
rusa raúl a ver rosa otros medios de
extranjeros como el new york times por
ejemplo también the gardian se fijan a
menudo en el racismo de francia y el
discurso anti migratorio esto tiene que
ver con las elecciones exacto raúl
porque digamos que ahí hay un pequeño
choque digamos cultural de visiones de
formas de ver el mundo y pues el new
york times the gardian y un poco lo que
se llama en francia los medios anglo
estadounidenses han criticado
recurrentemente la forma que tiene en
francia bajo el gobierno de macrón y
tantos otros de gestionar su pasado
colonial o pues la inmigración o también
el islam en francia tres cuestiones que
en ese país van de la mano en el debate
público y así es también en el marco de
esta campaña presidencial por un lado
pues el nivel
recuerda que no solamente la extrema
derecha en francia tiene discursos pues
contra el islam y también como decíamos
contra la migración y por otro lado the
guardian cita pues un poco la estrategia
que está utilizando valérie pécresse la
candidata de la derecha conservadora de
los republicanos que dice tras su caída
en los sondeos también está girando su
retórica cada vez más dura contra la
inmigración y que de hecho le
preguntaron por los electores que
preferían a la extrema derecha antes que
a ella y ella dijo que su programa era
más definido y más contundente repasamos
ahora entonces la prensa dentro de
francia dejamos con mediapart exacto
porque por otro lado media parte destaca
que en esta campaña en esta voluntad de
conquistar a la derecha moderada macrón
pues está intentando seducir a los
católicos de francia y ahora vemos que
dice le figaro en los últimos sondeos
rosa pues y aquí hemos querido pues
básicamente mostrarlo en pantalla no lo
que hemos venido comentando pues hace
pues en macrón sigue a la cabeza seguido
de lópez y en tercer lugar pues el
izquierdista jean luc mélenchon y en
cuarto lugar también en la polemista por
decirlo de algún modo también de extrema
derecha el ix de moore pero recordemos
también los sondeos muchas veces
influencian también en la propia campaña
y por otro lado hemos querido destacar
que le figaro pregunta a sus lectores
sobre el interés que tienen por estas
presidenciales no básicamente la
pregunta es tiene usted interés en estas
elecciones y hemos visto como gana el no
por encima del sí es un tema que vamos
ahora a hablar con nuestra invitada si
es rossi más a la izquierda que dice
liberación y aquí lo vamos a ver
liberación saca testigos de personas de
izquierda que dicen que su primera
opción no sería el candidato de la
francia insumisa del izquierdista jean
luc mansión pero que lo votarán pues en
una especie de voto útil no porque dicen
tal y como señala este titular será
menos violento que volver a tener a
macrón contra lepén
en la segunda vuelta de esta especie de
ramos esta revista de prensa antes de
pasar a hablar con nuestra invitada rosa
con algo que me encanta las caricaturas
exactamente no así aquí sí que
encontramos varias referencias a esta
cuestión en los medios franceses por un
lado pues el apoyo de este ex presidente
socialista de françois hollande digamos
que tras su mandato se hundió este
partido en francia y apoya anida algo la
alcaldesa de parís que es la candidata
de este partido a las presidenciales y
que está pues por los suelos en los
sondeos y por otro lado también tenemos
esta viñeta en liberación de coco
mientras está de media parte era de 7
queremos mencionar siempre los autores
bueno aquí también otra viñeta de 100
mil en sión puede despertar a la
izquierda no ya que un poco en la
postura del príncipe azul en referencia
a este mismo artículo de liberación a
que comentábamos y aquí tenemos a macrón
diciéndole pues a una persona digamos a
sin techo podría por favor reducir su
consumo de gas eso nos ayudaría mucho no
también un poco presentando macrón como
una figura siempre un poco autoritaria
por distintas salidas que ha tenido a lo
largo de estos cinco años de mandato así
es rosa gracias por esta información de
revista de prensa que esté con nosotros
para empezar a analizar toda esta previa
a la primera vuelta de las elecciones
francesas con nuestra segunda mitad del
día